[Applause]
okay thank you I know it's exciting
because it's Christmas time I love
Christmas in Los Angeles nothing beats
the smell of a chestnuts roasting on an
encampment
[Applause]
fire a Christmas I love any holiday
where you get to light at
kids
but but actually you know this week is
actually The Sweet Spot in the holiday
season right like between Thanksgiving
and Christmas when there's no relatives
in the house
I hate that you you sit on the toilet
and the seat is the temperature of
ass
so oh here's a sweet holiday story uh
Boston is having a segregated Christmas
party did you read about this the city
council it's a it's uh only 13
people seven white six people of color
but they had they had to like uninvite
the white people they had they this is a
scandal now because the mayor sent out a
thing and said only the electeds of
color that's the phrase electeds of
sounds like a Marvel movie I the elected
of I don't know why we have to separate
like this but okay so they don't like
the white folks at the party some people
are saying it's racist some people
saying it's possibly illegal but you
have to admit it makes the DJ's job a
lot
[Music]
easier
um
and it's Christmas at the white house uh
Biden never knows what to get Ukraine
you
know last last year he up and he
just did cash and
uh
Ukraine Ukraine burst into tears and
said you make me feel like like a
yeah yeah but you know I I tell
you yeah I don't know how you feel about
the bidens but that is a family that's
made for Christmas come on I mean you
seen the pictures Joe rapping the
president president Jill decorating the
tree Hunter bringing the
snow
well okay so get this now the house the
Republican house of course they have
voted to have a formal inquiry now into
impeaching Joe Biden they said it a
crucial step in pretending to have a
reason to impeach
him
uh but you know
look we all know he has a troubled son
Hunter we've all we've seen the pictures
the dick
the you know the hookers the cocaine I
mean you know know it's it's not pretty
here's the Republicans Theory while
they're impeaching him that Biden uh
President Biden profited off his
crackhead
son really that's their thing as any
parent of an addict will tell you that's
when the cash really starts
rolling uh i'
say I I thought it was a stretch when
they impeached Clinton over a
but
imping impeaching a guy over your son's
that that that seems a
Str and uh of
course A lot of these younger Dumber
Republicans they they
don't they don't know the constit they
don't know anything about impeachment uh
Lauren bobbert uh asked what did the
president know and what's it like to
know
things
that